[Music]
the movie opens in a new world where god
is a human-like entity with feelings
desires and emotions he lives in an
apartment in brussels which he shares
with his wife and his ten-year-old
daughter ia his older son j.c was a
rebel who wanted to do things his way
hence god doesn't like talking about him
even god doesn't know what to do about
puberty unlike how he is normally
painted this god is not a messiah or a
savior he is simply a creator who is
bored of designing things before
creating humans he made cities and towns
filled with only animals but such a
world was boring since animals didn't
create drama on their own hence god made
the first human in his skin named adam
after traveling the world he found a
woman named eve and instantly fell in
love being the first humans was a bit
difficult for the couple at first but
after trying a bunch of things in bed
they finally managed to get eve pregnant
their children multiplied over the years
and eventually humankind was formed one
big happy incest family god watches them
learn and grow but it all gets boring
after a while as time passes he turns
sadistic someone who gets high by making
people suffer he creates stupid rules
like a slice of bread will always fall
to the ground with the jam side down and
the line next to you in grocery stores
will always move quicker when the little
problems get old he creates bigger ones
like terrorism global warming poverty
natural calamities and so on even
outside of work god is a terrible
creature always bossing his wife around
and treating her like a lesser being he
is emotionally and physically abusive to
his daughter as well she can move things
with her mind like her older brother jc
but god doesn't allow her to use her
powers jealous that he doesn't have them
himself no one is allowed in his office
room where he keeps files and data about
humankind until one day ia finds the
door open and walks inside without her
father's knowledge in the middle of the
room is a computer that god uses to
control the entire world through the
computer ia discovers the many
catastrophes that her father has created
he has taken all of the ladders out of
the pools in the sims she is disgusted
at how he enjoys watching people drown
in misery hence at dinner that night she
calls him out for being a sadist an
enraged god whips her with his belt for
hours until his anger dies down by the
end of the torture ia has had enough she
decides to run away from home but since
it has no doors or windows she asks her
brother for help when she touches a
little statue in her room it comes to
life as jc and explains what she must do
next she should first get herself a
bunch of apostles someone who can be an
advocate for her policies and ideas jc
tried 12 and it was too messy so he asks
her to try getting only six apostles to
choose the set of postals she can just
randomly pick up six human cards from
her father's study then jc asks her to
write a brand new testament using the
apostles and their experiences that way
ia can contribute to the betterment of
humanity like jc once did to get her out
of the house he has hacked the dryer and
connected it to the human world after a
long chat es steals the key to the study
room from her father and retrieves six
human cards randomly before leaving she
hacks into his computer and sends a text
to every living human telling them the
exact day they are going to die ia just
wants to see the world burn this brings
chaos to the human world many people who
have less time on earth leave their jobs
and start doing things they always
wanted to do some eat whatever they like
initially people don't believe the text
messages but many coincidences happen in
relation to the texts making them come
to terms with their death dates the
scared ones do everything they can to
prevent their deaths but they ultimately
find out that it is inevitable as they
can die from simple accidents like a
cupboard falling on them this also sends
people into a moral dilemma and many
soldiers flee the war wanting to do
better with the time they have left as
the chaos continues ia goes into the
dryer and crawls along a long path until
she finally reaches the human world she
enjoys the rain for some time before
eating a burger from a dumpster when the
burger makes her sick she is helped by a
homeless man named victor she senses
that he is a good man and asks him to
help her write the testaments since she
is not good at writing herself initially
victor dismisses her request as childish
but when she continues following him he
agrees to help back at home god wakes up
and finds out that the world he created
is changing into a better place until
now the uncertain future made people
fear doing what they loved but with
their lifetime in front of them they can
choose whatever they want to do with
their lives this brings people joy which
is against god's wish of how humans
should be he quickly goes to his
computer to change the settings but
finds out that it has been hacked ia's
smell is lingering around the house and
by following it he finds the pathway
located in the dryer at this moment he
decides to go into the world he created
to teach his daughter a lesson back on
earth victor and ia go to their first
apostle named orally she is a beautiful
woman wanted by many men and envied by
every woman she meets however she is
always sad and frequently blames her
life for being unfair it turns out that
when she was a teen orally lost her left
arm and has been wearing prosthetics
ever since ia asks her to talk about her
life so they can extract the important
parts to write into the new testament
victor gets ready with a pen and a piece
of paper to note down orally's life
lessons she starts by saying that the
most crucial moment of her life was not
when she lost her arm it was when she
met a homeless man one day he told her
that life is like a skating rink where a
lot of people fall it was a simple
sentence that many people would
interpret in the ways they like however
too orally the sentence gave her life a
new meaning she knows she has already
had her fall and has been trying to get
up for several years ia understands her
concerns and asks her to wait for a
miracle that is about to happen shortly
at night orally dreams of reuniting with
her hand she comes to terms with her
disability and finally gets up from the
skating rink that the homeless man told
her about after orally ia moves on to
the second apostle jean in his childhood
gene loved adventures and always wanted
to explore the world but when reality
hit he got stuck in a 9-5 job dedicating
his life to climbing the corporate
ladder when he found out that he has 12
years to live he didn't want to work
anymore hence he sat down on a park
bench and hasn't moved ever since he
spends his day looking at things around
him and feeding birds ia finds him on
the same park bench and sits down to
chat she can talk to animals and offers
to translate gene's words to a bird gene
wants to ask the bird why it never flies
away from the park when it has wings to
travel anywhere in the world in turn the
bird asks gene the same question whoa
that bird is deep the question brings
clarity to gene's mind and he sets off
on a journey to find himself at the same
time god finally reaches the other end
of the tunnel and enters the human world
he is instantly troubled by the world he
programmed when a lady pepper sprays him
for being a creep as he tries eating a
burger from the garbage can he is
attacked by the street gangs later he is
taken to the hospital where he gets into
a fight with the doctor after insulting
him still not coming to terms with a
human's way of life he steals a kid's
sandwich and is beaten by the mother
meanwhile ia looks for the third apostle
named mark he is a sex addict whose only
wish in life is to get in bed with as
many women as possible his addiction
started when he saw a girl on the beach
at the start of his teenage years after
finding out he has around 80 days to
live he took all the money out of the
bank and has been spending it on
prostitutes every night however it
hasn't provided him with ultimate
happiness and he is still longing for
something deeper ia tells him that he
has a beautiful voice and asks him to do
something with it she is sure that the
path will lead him to happiness the next
day mark gets the job as a voice actor
and meets a woman at work she turns out
to be the same girl who he saw at the
beach a long time ago
they instantly feel the chemistry
between them and go back to his place
for the first time in mark's life he
feels a connection deeper than his
sexual urges and they fall asleep
holding hands in the meantime god's wife
is enjoying time alone without her
husband while cleaning the house she
notices that three more apostles have
been added to the picture of the last
supper somewhere else god ends up in a
church thinking that it is the one place
he will be respected but he is beaten
for cutting a line to the food the
pastor helps him and feeds him but god
repays his kindness by insulting the man
and making fun of his life even the calm
pastor loses his cool and abuses him
meanwhile ia and victor make their way
to the next apostle named francois for
the last week he has turned into an
assassin after finding out that he has
25 years left to live he thinks that he
is not doing anything wrong by killing
people since the ones who die at his
hands were supposed to die anyway one
day he is on a mission when ia
approaches him asking him to target a
specific lady the lady turns out to be
orally hence when the bullet hits her
prosthetic arm francois thinks it is a
miracle that she doesn't die intrigued
he follows her for the rest of the day
and is smitten by her beauty he falls in
love but keeps on denying it to himself
until one day when he buys orally
flowers gathering much courage francois
hands them to her expressing his love
orally accepts them but gives him no
reply then ia visits the fifth apostle
martine she used to be a hopeless
romantic who is now stuck in a loveless
marriage she found out that her husband
is going to outlive her for 30 years and
has been sulking ever since she even
tries hooking up with random men to get
rid of her loneliness but nothing works
ia meets her and senses that she is
being called by someone in the circus
martine takes her word and the three go
to a circus later that day there martine
locks eyes with a gorilla and instantly
feels a connection to it knowing that he
is her one chance at happiness she buys
the animal from the circus at night they
connect and martine ends up kissing him
this movie has derailed entirely
somewhere else orly calls francois and
the two decide to meet orly shows him
her prosthetic arm and he kisses it
showing that he loves every part of her
they make love and francois finally
finds happiness outside of killing
people the following morning god is
wandering down a street when he sees ia
and victor he chases them but they
manage to escape by walking on water
when god tries to do it he almost drowns
and loses the other two a group of men
from the church save him and bring him
back to the pastor but even he doesn't
want to take care of the guy after that
ia finds her last apostle a boy named
willy who is about to die from a
terminal illness his last wish in life
is to dress up as a girl and his parents
allow him to do so ian makes friends
with him and gives him a shining fish as
a gift before dying willie wants to send
the fish to the sea on monday he sells
all of his parents furniture to travel
to a beach that he always wanted to
visit on tuesday francois tells orly
that he is in love with her and wants to
spend the rest of his life with her
wednesday is the day when martin's
husband finds her in bed with the
gorilla they kick him out of the house
and continue their romantic relationship
then thursday comes and mark makes love
to his girlfriend for the first time on
friday rebecca black pops off also gene
follows a flock of birds and reaches a
place in the arctic there the birds
signal him to a woman who happens to be
his soul mate and on the last day of the
week god is deported to uzbekistan with
a group of illegal immigrants at the
same time willie and the others come to
the beach where he sets the fish free he
is only a few minutes away from dying so
the group decides to stay on the beach
until his final breath in the meantime
god's wife enters his office to clean it
she unplugs the computer which sends the
entire world into a frenzy the airplane
that god is in starts to descend towards
the beach threatening to kill everyone
thankfully she plugs the computer in
again just in time to avoid the crash
she then proceeds to make personalized
changes in the world giving every human
the gift of a mortal life the sky is
covered with flowers people can walk
underwater with their pet fishes the
rules of gravity can be bent and the
world turns into a utopia where all
dreams are fulfilled and everything is
possible martine has a human baby with
the gorilla victor publishes the new
testament and becomes a renowned author
francois is pregnant with aurelie's
child and lastly ia and willie kiss each
other the only character who doesn't
have a happy ending is god who is stuck
in uzbekistan without a family he
desperately spends the rest of his days
looking into every dryer for a way to
return home subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching